Our task is to add an instance variable that counts the number of passengers.
Here it is. Here I want to add a passenger to this car, so we will increment
our counter. But, of course, there's a twist. You can only add a passenger if
there's room. So, we need to check if the number of passengers plus the one
that I want to add is less than the number of seats. Why not less equal than
the number of seats? I still need one seat for the driver. So only in that case
do I increment. So when I talk about patterns in general, the pattern that I
described here says increment the counter, but it doesn't mean that you'll
always have to increment the counter. The patterns gives you the broad outline
of what you have to do, and the details are different, in every situation.
After all if it was that simple, then you wouldn't be making the big bucks
figuring out the answers. Finally, the getPassengerCount really is as simple as
you think, here we just return the numberOfPassengers. The point is again,
knowing that many classes keep a counter can help you when you have a situation
where that is appropriate. Here, at the counter, you figure how does the count
change, that's the case here. Here we increment the counter, and then here we
have a simple and boring method to return. In this example, we just counted the
number of passengers. What if we wanted to know who's actually in the car?
We'll turn to that next.